A new superhero might be about
to land in the DC Universe — but
are fans feeling terrific about
this new addition… or terrible?
James Gunn continues to stir speculation
about the future of his DC Universe,
having now tweeted a captionless photo
of the superhero Mister Terrific. The
character is well known to comic book fans as a
brilliant mind capable of competing with Bruce
Wayne's skills of detection, strategy, and
engineering. He was a significant part of DC
Comics' universe-wide "Futures End" story
arc during the New 52 era, and recently
served as the primary antagonist of Tom King's
Black Label maxi-series Strange Adventures.
Black Adam's Hawkman actor Aldis Hodge
recently told GamesRadar that he'd like
to do a team-up film featuring both
his character and Mister Terrific,
with his brother, Edwin Hodge, reprising
the role from the 2021 film Injustice.
The character has been voiced by
numerous actors over the years,
from Michael Beach in Justice League Unlimited to
comedian Hannibal Buress in Justice League Action.
"Saved by the bell. It’s time to T up."
The character made his live-action debut in
the TV series Arrow, played by Echo Kellum.
"Nice aim."
"That’s the
thing, they aim themselves."
Gunn's photo comes from an early 2000s issue
of Justice Society of America, illustrated
by legendary comic book artist Alex Ross, and it
has sparked countless casting theories from fans.
One Twitter user suggested The Good
Place star William Jackson Harper,
an actor who recently made superhero
headlines after his casting in Ant-Man:
Quantumania led to rumors that he
would play the MCU's Mister Fantastic.
"Put the Peeps in the chili
pot, it makes it taste… bad…"
Coming off the back of the final season
of Atlanta, another Twitter user wrote:
"Lakeith Stanfield please James!!!"
Another user suggested Jonathan Majors,
who recently made his MCU debut in Loki
and is set to play the franchise's
next big bad: Kang the Conqueror.
"Not every version of me
was so, so pure of heart."
Meanwhile, one Twitter user suggested
This Is Us actor Sterling K. Brown.
Brown recently starred in the film
Honk For Jesus. Save Your Soul,
but is more widely known to superhero fans as the
brother of King T'Chaka in 2018's Black Panther.
Gunn has been relatively open about his
role as the new co-head of the DC Universe,
seemingly eager to reassure fans that their wishes
will be considered under his leadership. Still,
the question of Mister Terrific is a tricky
one. While he's definitely a popular character,
he's also a member of an ensemble and not
considered one of the "main" characters in the
DC universe. Many fans were excited about the
potential for more projects about the Justice
Society of America, but some were apprehensive
about the idea of DC jumping straight into a
Mr. Terrific project without establishing
him in another film. One user suggested:
"Set up [the main characters], then start working
on DC's large list of other characters to add in."
All in all, fans' reaction
to Gunn's post seems to be
a mixture of excitement that their favorite
character might be adapted for the screen,
and concern that the filmmakers might screw
it up. Such is the life of a comic book fan.